i left off a negative sign there
it's just silly to me because the
negative always follows cosec so anyway
make sure you've updated that on your
table i wrote it down right when i was
working it out and then i forgot to put
it here so
there's our basic functions our
reciprocal functions let's do our
inverse ones and i figure i should redo
this with you number one because some of
the later questions
will deal with them and number two i
remember when we were related rates and
i said hey guys remember the derivatives
in the inverse trig functions and
everyone gave me this sort of blank
stare so
let's just re-get them they're not that
hard to get and also it's an opportunity
we can use implicit differentiation to
work these out even though it doesn't
work out to be that different
so before we dive into
doing these there's a little bit of um
there's a couple of identities which
will help us to simplify these results
okay so you start with the pythagorean
identity this is where so many other
results come from right and if you want
to get sine x or cos x on their own out
of this identity what would you do
well for sine
you kick the cos squared over and then
you would take the square root
right so i'm going to put that down
that's 1 minus
cos squared is that okay and in the same
way i can do that for sine so one minus
sounds good okay this will become handy
later i don't know if you recognize
these as forming parts of the
denominators of the derivatives for the
inverse trig functions but they'll come
up in a second
and then secondly um when you take your
whole identity and you divide through by
cos squared this is an important one
because um this is what relates sex
squared and tan squared that's a
familiar one right but in my case when i
get to inverse tan
i actually want cos squared so
i got to this line by dividing every
term by cos squared but now here i'll
just take the reciprocal of both sides
so i'm going to end up with 1 plus 10
squared
over here okay
right now when we start on something
like y equals sine inverse
because i don't know anything yet about
sine inverse i want to get it in terms
of functions i do know about like say
sine and cos okay so let's do that i'm
going to have to take sine of both sides
which leaves you here
now before in our earlier proof
you may remember what we did was instead
of taking 2 and dx
we differentiated instead with respect
to y so i took dx on dy and then i
flipped things later on and that worked
fine okay that's still a fine method to
do it to get this result but you guys
know how to do this implicitly
maybe we should give that a go since we
are after the derivative with respect to
x after all okay so i'm going to take
the derivative of both sides
with respect
to x okay this is the way implicit works
remember now on the right hand side the
derivative of x is just one okay so
that's what you get
you know left hand side remember the key
to implicit differentiation is to think
of that y as a function because you know
that that is what it is right so if i if
it's a function this is a function of a
function it's chain rule okay so what
you do is you differentiate the inside
first which is just d y and the x
yeah and then you differentiate the
outside the outside function is sine so
i'm going to end up with
cos
okay now what was i after i was after d
y and dx okay so
i'll bring that
over the other side
plus x okay and now you can see why i
was bothering with this result here
because i want to get things back in
terms of sines because that's what my
original function was defined as okay so
i'll write this as the square root of
sorry 1 on
the square root of
that right except sine x sine x is just
uh
wait wait i write that sorry i
you guys missed it that's a y
that's better um always tricky with your
variables which one's your you've got so
be careful with them
sine y is just x right so that's why on
the bottom here i've got the square root
of 1 minus x squared
okay
so that's the general pattern of how it
works you can actually see the implicit
bit doesn't hang around for very long
the rest of this is exactly the same as
if you'd gone from here and taken dx on
d1
okay really quickly even though you can
probably anticipate the result for this
um off of what we got for sine inverse
let's do it again because it's not that
hard and i'll give you some
give you some practice with implicit
what do i do here uh let's let's skip
this step because i think you guys can
see it let's let's do it in our heads on
the right hand side when i differentiate
with respect to x i'll just get
one
over here when i differentiate i've got
chain rule so i'll do the inside which
gives me d y on dx and then i've got the
outside which is
minus sine right so minus sine
y
then as i did before
i'll toss that over the other side
okay and now i use this identity here
minus 1 over
and of course cos y is just x so
that's how you get this result
which is exactly what you ought to
expect because these are really the same
graph but in reversed and of course
they're they're shifted up and down as
well
okay last one here we go take 10 on both
sides
and now we differentiate implicitly so
on the left hand side i'll do the inside
which gives me dyna dx
then you do your outside which gives you
cos
sorry sex squared right because it's
just 10. so sex squared y and then
differentiate the right hand side gives
you 1.
so dy and dx i'm going to multiply
through by cos squared
and that's just this right you see that
so d y and the x is
one over and this is why it has no
um square root signs okay that's how you
remember but this is the different one
ten y is just x so
ta-da
so not too difficult okay uh we are
gonna be doing a lot of work with
integrals that start like this okay
where you've got to integrate something
like this and that therefore we're gonna
end back up with sine inverse cos
inverse tan inverse as the primitive
function okay